as a palate cleanser to the talent show
figured we'd have some real talent will
have little brows wrap us the way out
gunship and we got a little video for it
well okay you'll see here's a go bro
[Music]
yeah sharp records let's go shout out to
the culture corner yeah let's go look
Brennan and do fighter bird wait I got
to go in and go hard in the paint I do
not think I am in flow like rifle coffee
I'm ready to go
I need a sponsor I am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contained just browse particular girls
there is the great famous damn hunky
like a fresh off kiddo
see my red like Andrew Santino every
song I hit like the great Bambino
Brennan ate the case so in the case
Cerritos but everything's gonna be fine
they hate on me I do not mind
hey you're looking like the type of do
the gutter case a mountain Dew on and at
all times
they sliding into my dance a couple of
I'm trying to cut and beat them
quit playing a Nintendo DS you don't
want to smoke like Joey Diaz meaning
you're edible just got my eyebrows
threaded and I'm pinning and cut the
burning Sun hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club did you pick me up King
in this state hey King in this state
King in a sting bee sting back King
yeah King and the sting yeah King and I
stay left beez in the trap got a cheese
in a string gasps King and the sting
yeah King in the sting
yes King that's a big bee sting Rat King
is pink and the sting yeah King and I
stink
got that beez in the trap got a cheese
on a string
it's my favorite episode bro that [ __ ]
was hard
congratulations brows thank you so much
man universe yeah yeah max respect just
added a whole new level to the show and
uh and thank you so much and thank you
CAD and chin and Nick and Chappell
thank you brother yeah bro keep touching
me dawg
[Music]